[Alkış]
Merhaba ben Eczacı Ayşe Uzunlu bugün
burada Sizin karşınızda olmamda
Kayseri'de uzun yıllardır kadın hak
temelli bir derneğin Başkanı olarak
çalışıyor olmamın etkisi büyük burada
bir eş bir anne meslek sahibi bir kadın
ve bir sivil toplum gönüllüsü olarak
konuşacağım
cumhuriyetin sağladığı fırsat
eşitliğinden faydalanarak iyi eğitim
almış sosyal ve ekonomik hayatta var
olabilmiş özgür bir kadın olarak
karşınızdayım
Türkiye'nin en köklü en yaygın ve eski
kadın Derneği olan Türk kadınlar
birliğinin Kayseri şubesinin başkanıyım
sizlerle bu Dernek çatısı altında nasıl
çalıştığımı ve edindiğim deneyimlerimi
paylaşacağım
Benim Hikayem 5 çocuklu bir ailenin 4
çocuğu olarak başladı Bizleri yetiştirip
hayata hazırlayan Annen ve baban
eğitimin önemine inanarak hepimizin
hepimize aynı imkanları sunarken
özellikle hepimizin iyi bir eğitim
olmasını istediler evde ilkokuldan
liseye her eğitim kademesinde 5 çocuktuk
hepimizin harçlığı eşitti yaşımızın
cinsiyetimizin hiç önemi yoktu Bugün
bile birçok ailede böyle bir eşitlik
modeli olduğunu düşünmüyorum ben Sevgiyi
saygıyı ve özellikle eşitliği ailemden
öğrendim
eğitim hayatım boyunca akademik anlamda
başarılı bir öğrenciydim sosyal
etkinliklere katılım sağlardım Hacettepe
Üniversitesi eczacılık fakültesini
bitirip evlendim Kayseri'ye yerleştirdim
Kayseri Sosyal Sigortalar Kurumu
Hastanesi'nde çalışırken
Anne Olunca çevremde çalışmam
sorgulamaya başladı
ikinci kez anne olduğunda bu sorgulanma
sanki başkalarının benim yerime karar
verme hakkı varmış gibi daha gür sesli
dile getirilmeye başlandı
Bu arada
Kayınvalidemin rahatsızlığı
nedeniyle bakıma ihtiyaç duyması İşimi
daha da zorlaştırdı
hastanede Geceleri nöbet tutuyordum
nöbet sayısı çok fazlaydı
Eşimin de doktor olması nedeniyle
nöbetlerimiz çakışınca istemeden 5 yılın
sonunda resmi çalışma hayatımı bitirmek
zorunda kaldım
aile yaşamıyla iş yaşamını birlikte
yürütebilmem için benim kendi eczanemi
açmam gerekliydi o günler Bana kendi
hayatlarımın üzerinde durabilmek için iş
ve aile yaşamı arasında denge kurmayı
Çalışma Hayatında var olabilmek için
mücadele etmeyi öğretti
kadınların çalışması ile ilgili kalıp
yargılar
toplum baskısı
daima kadınların üzerine bırakılmış
çocuk yaşlı bakım sorumluluğu
o yıllarda olduğu gibi
hala kadınların Ayağında bir pranga gibi
duruyor
bütün geriye dönüp baktığımda Çalışma
Hayatında kalarak ne kadar iyi yaptım
görüyorum kariyer sahibiyim Mutlu bir
ailem var
Fakat bu günlere gelebilmenin zorlu bir
yolculuk istediğini
deneyimlerimle öğrendim bu birçok kadın
için hala çok zor ilk okulda Kızılay
kolu ile başlayan gönüllülük hayatım
bugün Türk Kadınlar Birliği başta olmak
üzere Atatürkçü düşüncede Derneği
Kapadokya organik tarım Derneği tohumluk
Vakfı buğday Derneği LÖSEV ufak
kayseri'liler iş kadınları Derneği gibi
sivil toplum örgütlerinde devam ediyor
kolay yolu seçmedim
ilgi alanıma giren konularda çalışmaya
gayret ediyorum
1996 yılında Türk kadınlar birliğinin
Kayseri şubesinin kurulmasıyla sivil
toplum hayatına adım attım kadın kafası
kafamın bir kenarında şekillenmeye
başlamıştı ama o zamanlar ben daha çok
çevre konusunda duyarlı bir aktivistim
ağaç dikme atık değerlendirme 5
torbaların kullanılması tıbbi
atıklardaki tehlikeye dikkat çektik
iklim değişikliğinden dolayı yaşadığımız
doğal afetler zamanında alınmayan
önlemler bugün canımızı çok yakıyor
yıllar önce bunları yaparken bugün hala
o bilinç seviyesinin üzerine çıkamamak
ne acı
2000 yılında dernekte Başkan oldum
o yıl aileden sorumlu devlet Bakanlığı
tarafından Türkiye'de tüm illerde çok
sayıda kadına ulaşılacak 2000 yılı kadın
toplantıları yapma kararı alındı
ülkemizde kadınların güçlenmesi için
yoğun çalışmalar başladı Kayseri'de
valiliğimizin koordinasyonu ile il ve
ilçelerde yapılan çalışmalarda
eğitimcilerle birlikte yer alıyor
kadınlara kız ve erkek çocuklarını eşik
yetiştirmeleri aynı eğitim imkanı
vermeleri gerektiğini anlatıyorduk
o gündür bu gündür kadınların eşitlik
mücadelesi için çalışmaya devam ediyorum
okuma yazma kursları resmî nikah kız
çocuklarının erken evlendirilmesinin
önlenmesi ev ekonomisi hiç Yani
girişimcilik kooperatifleşme aile için
meslek becerileri kazandırma gibi
kadınları bilinçlendiren onlara güç ve
güven veren her türlü eğitim çalışmaları
yapıyorduk rol modeller olarak biz
yapıyoruz Siz de yapabilirsiniz diyerek
kadınlara ve kız çocuklarına onu
taşıyorduk
toplantılar hep kadınlarla yapılıyordu
2000 yılında ileri yaşta Bilge Bir kadın
Bir ilçede yaptığımız farkındalık
çalışmaları sırasında
Bunlar neden kadınlara anlatılıyor
Neden erkekler dinlemiyor onlara da
anlatılmalı diyerek noktayı koydu bu
cümleyi hiç unutamam
o zamana kadar kulunun uzmanları
tarafından fark edilmeyen bir konuyu bir
babaanne dile getirmişti
benim deneyimime olan saygı bir kez daha
arttı
yine 8 Mart Dünya Kadınlar Günü 25 Kasım
şiddetle mücadele günü 5 Aralık Türk
kadınını seçme ve seçilme hakkını
kazanmasının günü gibi kadın
mücadelesinin önemli günlerinde
farkındalık bir bilgilendirme oluşturmak
için çabası gösteririz bütün bunları
yaparken yanımda yönetim kurulundan
arkadaşlarım
üyelerimiz şehrimizde kadın
mücadele'sine destek verene
kadın konusunda birlikte hareket etmek
kültürünü oluşturmaya çalıştık bunu da
başardık diye düşünüyorum
örgütü Mücadele'nin gücüne inanıyorum
Türk Kadınlar Birliği
kadın konusunda çatışmak için çok
değerli bir alan yaşanan bütün sosyal
sorunlar kadınları ve çocukları derinden
etkiler Onun için bir kadın stk'sında
çalışıyor olma toplumun bu günü ve
yarına için çok önemli bir konumdur
çok iyi ünlü bir mücadele dikkat
ederseniz hep kadın mücadelesi denir
Evet bu kadının insan hakları
mücadelesidir ama asla bir kavga
değildir bilgiyle akılla yürütülmesi
gereken uzun bir yolculuktur
Milli Mücadele'deki kadınlarımızın
hedefi bağımsız bir ülkeydi
Onun için cephe ve cephe gerisinde
mücadele ettiler devamında Cumhuriyetle
birlikte
Nezih Muhittin'in öncülüğünde kadınların
sosyal siyasal ekonomik haklarının
kazanılması için çok çalıştılar
siyasi görüşleri farklı olmasına rağmen
eşitlik mücadelesinde omuz omuzaydılar
Biz o kadınların torunlarıyız
Bugün bize düşen görev siyasi düşüncemiz
ne olursa olsun kadınların insan
haklarını savunmaktır
çalışmalarım sırasında hiçbir siyasi
partiye yaslanmadım
sivil toplum örgütlerinde çalışanlar
ayrım gözetmeksizin herkesin sesi
olabilmeli
dünyada ve ülkemizde kadına çocuğa
yaşlıya yönelik şiddet artarken bana ne
deyip Susmalı mıyım
iklim değişikliği doğal afetler
çocuklarımızın torunlarımızın geleceğini
tehdit ederken görmezden mi gelmeliyim
mesleğin çocukların seni geçindirecek
paran var Sana ne kadın haklarından
herkes tercihini Yaşar diyenlerden mi
olmalıyım
kadına şiddet konusunu ve kadın
haklarını çok konuşuyorsun
yoksa Eşin sana Şiddet mi gösteriyor
diyen soğuk espriler karşısında
şaşırmalı mıyım
bu kadar çalıştığında ne elde ettin
diyenlere cevabım şudur
Evet gün oldu sorunlar denedi
gözüme uyku Girmedi ama gün oldu
çok büyük mutlulukları gururu sivil
toplum çalışmalarında Buldum kendimi
geliştirerek yürüdüğüm yolun doğru
olduğuna inanarak önüne çıkan engelleri
aldırmadan bugünlere geldim ben bir
kadın hakları savunucusuyum
Bunun yanı sıra dünyanın ve ülkenin
geleceğinde gördüğün her tehditle
mücadele etmek için çalışıyorum yaşanan
olumsuzluklardan kendini sorumlu tutuyor
kötü olduğum düşündüğüm şeyleri
değiştirmek istiyorum
siyasete girmeden çizgimi bozmadan
bilgim deneyimim duruşumla Ben olarak
ama bize inanarak örgütlü bir mücadele
gerçekleştiriyorum
Yasama yürütme yargı ve medyanın yanında
5 güç sayılan sivil toplum
çalışmalarında tarafsız bir gönüllüyüm
onun için bugün Farklı görüş ve
düşüncedeki birçok kişinin Ayşe
ablasıyım
geleceğimizin bugünden daha iyi olması
gerekmez mi
insanı ve toplumu konu alan birçok
çalışma teknolojik yenilikler gelecekte
insanların daha rahat yaşama
kavuşmalarına mutluluğuna sebebe
olmayacaksa ne anlamı var
Ben görevimi yaptım
bayrağı Deniz Dilek Gözde Cennet Fatma
ve Gülce alacak Hatta
Aliler Meteler artık erkeklerin de elini
taşın altına koyma zamanı gelmedi mi
görünüyor ki sürekli çok uzun
o zaman
geleceğimizi Umut olmak için gönüllü
olmalıyız ilgi ve bilgi alanımıza göre
Elimizi taşın altına koymalıyız
geleceğimiz için emek vermeliyiz ancak
kararlı bir şekilde çalışarak ve
Birlikten güç alarak sorunların
üstesinden gelebiliriz
Bu sırada bilgi sevgi saygı ahlak Vicdan
bize yol gösterecektir
sorunları konuşanlardan değilim
çözümün parçası olanlarından Ben Ayşe
Uzunlu Ben bir Atatürk kızıyım ve bir
Cumhuriyet kadınıyım
[Alkış]